mit ihrem einsatz bewegen wir kultur und
swisslos wünschte ihnen viel vergnügen
ach was sehen wir uns momentan alle nach
berührungen auch endo anaconda geht so
doch in zeiten von corona kommen wir uns
allenfalls durch glasscheiben wie hier
giacobbo müller auf exklusivem zu besuch
[Musik]
auf kuschelkurs mit dem kulturplatz
heute herzlich willkommen in
trubschachen wo ich gerade warte ich
warte wie diese reisende hier und wie
krisenbedingt ja eigentlich grad die
ganze menschheit auch aber ich freue
mich denn ich warte auf einen musiker
den ich persönlich sehr schätze
nicht zuletzt auch als manchmal
unbequeme stimme unseres landes ich
warte auf endo anaconda erst gerade hat
er das letzte album seiner karriere
erfolgreich veröffentlicht und gleich
danach musste er sich wegen corona von
seiner eigenen abschiedstour vorerst
verabschieden
der stille hassall zu stillen
ja die kultur museums branche liegt im
dornröschenschlaf deshalb hatten wir
kuratoren und direktorinnen angefragt ob
sie uns eintritt gewähren uns und
prominenten kulturschaffenden um einen
blick zu werfen in ihrer derzeit
verwaisten institutionen und somit
können wir nun in den nächsten wochen
exklusiv ganz besondere einblicke
ermöglichen seien anfang macht das
komiker-duo giacobbo müller und
natürlich gleich auch alles etwas anders
[Musik]
muslim sei gut so aber besser ein besuch
im menschenleeren zuzüglich das war der
wunsch der tierliebhaber giacobbo müller
und viktor giacobbo und mike müller
kennen direktor alex rübel seit jahren
auch bei der feierlichen eröffnung der
leber savanne die anfang april wegen
corona ins wasser fiel wäre das duo mit
von der partie gewesen statt
massenandrang steht jetzt ein exklusiver
rundgang auf dem programm
tür und tor stehen den unerwarteten
besuchern offen eine willkommene
abwechslung in der krise auch für die
besuchten
das seit wochen fehlende publikum machte
gerade den menschenaffen zu schaffen die
man als erster mensch fixierte fußböden
jetzt ist natürlich sie wieder große
attraktion genau
für maik ritschel sollten sie bei
rohkaffees herzlicher ja auch ganz
mechanisch tipptopp problem mit der
fertig sieht ein problem der fdp sie
weiter
[Musik]
viktor giacobbo engagiert sich auch
privat kämpft als stiftungsrat der
gemeinnützigen organisation panico unter
anderem gegen illegale gefangenschaft
von orang utans auf sumatra
alex rübel amtet in der stiftung als
beirat schlicht atemberaubend einblick
über die neue liga savanne und die hand
immer so genannte katja dieckow aus
grieche urteilen und das hören dass die
56.000 quadratmeter große savanne wegen
eines virus' sang und klanglos eröffnet
werden musste ein wermutstropfen für
alex rübel so kurz vor seiner
pensionierung im zu kommen derzeit
allein die tiere auf ihre kosten
weiter geht's doch das und mehr sehen
sie am 5
bei kulturplatz extra sogar ist es
könnten der pcx zu ihrem freund fahren
als grandios wanderer was das thema ist
sie wäre gegangen
das ist wie früher mitunter richtig
losgeht allerdings sechs kilometer
[Musik]
noch eine show
es war schön
also wenn du kramen sie sprechen sich
die bremse auf dem weg nach langnau
bewegung gegen den stillstand spazieren
um zu sinnieren über corona und diese
zumindest gefühlte zeitenwende
zunächst gibt es für dich ende eine art
liebeserklärung eines kollegen musik
redakteurs richard herolz denen eine
musik seit den 80er jahren begleitet er
wirft einen blick auf diese karriere
dieses mannes sehr bald 65 wird positiv
du bist seit über 30 jahren mein
musikalischer begleiter ein funkelnder
sternen der sonst möglichen welt von
alperose und scharlachrote des berner
mundart rock der vater schweizer die
mutter aus österreich andreas flückiger
so heißt du ja eigentlich aus ende der
berner kurzform von andreas wurde endo
[Musik]
du hast uns hymnen des alltags geschenkt
große wort kunst aus scheinbar banalen
geformt ein schonungslos sezierenden
blick auf die kleingeistige schweiz der
mann nirgends entkommt unübertroffen
[Musik]
sie brauchen
wie hast du dich über die grassierende
genussfähigkeit ereifern können die
sterberate beträgt immer noch 100
prozent sein lakonischer schluss
und kein gutes leben ohne laster später
gar das bekenntnis vom harry nicht
gelassen zu haben
aber irgendwann machte der knappe alters
nicht mehr mit so bist du heute
vielleicht nicht geläutert aber doch
gekleidet im besten sinn und letzten und
einzigen tier frei der stille haas
verstummt bald für immer
doch zuvor hast du uns noch das album
pfadfinder geschickt ein stimmiges
alterswerk mit deiner uhr eigenen
handschrift
paradies und berührend gibt
[Musik]
mit
ja die spurs auf der hut
louis sogenannte stumme wer getriebe
stift von denen ist alles drin adriani
april der hass der beißt ins gras der
indo aber der witz überleben
[Musik]
mit
pz wie gut es war bestand an 18 tischen
bezirksfrauen wir machen das jetzt
telefoniert mit einer fülle von ihre
jahr verstaatlicht im vorfeld der
sächsische privatmenschen kuschel
primaten sie eindeutig private ohne
empathie eine körperlichkeit juni zeit
lag etwa die statik primaten hierzu homo
sapiens wurde verdammt ihn überzeugt das
heißt ich glaube mit mancher kritiker
physischer kontakt bietet sie irgendwo
israel itc würde jetzt klein vitrine
münchen der für minimum arme wie es im
beruf besser am ende das geld ja nicht
verwechselt 6 m mit lea bisher
umfassende dass sich ja irgendwie ein
philosophischer überbau und das ist aber
gerade kulturen das macht kultur nicht
wen ich glaube dass sie jetzt irgendwer
also was mich betrifft war es nicht
unbedingt zur fahrt nach sommerurlaub am
ende so unnötige spanien geführtes spiel
womit sie terminalbau am telefon und
positive ausstrahlung auf mehr oder
bringt mir das mal machen
wir konnten dort im und sie liegen
gesicht und sehnsucht die liebe hat es
derzeit nicht leicht die einen hocken
unfreiwillig aufeinander die anderen
zerfließen vor sehnsucht nacheinander
und wiederum dritte wissen überhaupt
nicht wie sie einem möglichen partner
irgendwie nahe kommen könnten
aber der kummer mit der liebe der muss
nicht sein aber style durchbohrt jedes
plexiglas vielleicht schießt der
göttliche sogar treffsicherer als zu
fordern jetzt ist die zeit der waren am
liebe überwindet alle hindernisse wie
bei der zürcher regisseur ingmar frayn
berlin mitten in der korona zeit hat sie
hier ihren partner bei kinder
kennengelernt
wenige tage vor dem lock dorn sind sie
zusammengekommen
die krise hat dieser neuen liebe den
entscheidenden schub verdient ich das
richtig und wird das und jetzt ist das
einfach
ich würde sagen das ist es sehr sehr
beschleunigt hat man durfte sich ja dann
oder sollte ja dann muss ich nur noch
mit zwei kontaktpersonen treffen und
somit war das dann für uns eigentlich
logisch dass wir dann einfach diese zeit
dann auch miteinander verbracht haben
hier draußen ist krise und drinnen piola
elf jahre lang war consumer free single
und müde von den unendlichen dating
optionen
das neo paar musste radikalen scheiden
voneinander lassen oder gemeinsam in die
liebes isolation
es hätte auch für und eine
belastungsprobe dann aber das klingt
jetzt richtig doof was ich sage
franz ist mega gut im haushalt und franz
hat kann sehr gut backen und wenn man
hier jeden samstag einen kuchen backt
dann bin ich natürlich sowieso lieber
bedeutet freiheit liebe bedeutet
problemen
[Musik]
formation für das kennenlernen so die
philosophin für erika gregor a tor kann
eine krisensituation wie ein katalysator
wirken in der erste phase des
kennenlernens gelten werden gleich mehr
also wörter und erzählungen und ihr logo
und konversation gelten ja um dialoge
und konversation sind nach zum beispiel
aristotle er war auch seine gar auch die
essenz der liebe und freundschaft die
pandemie zeit wird für mara für immer
mit schach verknüpft sein
die 39 jährige zürcherin hat im lockdown
ihren neuen partner gefunden einen
passionierten schachspieler die liebe so
fesch dass sie zwar darüber erzählen mag
aber nicht erkennbar sein will
wir haben uns gefragt was machen wir
jetzt
ich spürte das ist ein mensch den ich
besser kennen lernen möchte und nicht
einfach aufgeben wegen corona dieses
risiko wollte ich nicht eingehen
das war dann ein schlüsselmoment maras
gedanken
nehme ich jetzt diesen mann oder keinen
will ich mit ihm durch die ausnahme zeit
gehen oder allein bleiben die typische
single angst vor der einsamkeit
potenziert sich jetzt plötzlich bist du
mit corona auf null gesetzt und damit
fallen fast alle möglichkeiten weg dann
verbringt man natürlich viel zeit zu
zweit das vertrauen wächst schneller und
damit auch der wunsch sich näher zu
kommen und sich zu küssen
[Musik]
die multi options- gesellschaft muss
wegen corona pausieren finden sich jetzt
paare zusammen ist das liebe oder
einfach pragmatismus sicherheit sei eine
wichtige komponente für die liebe sagt
philosophin für erika gregor aber die
liebe benötige das gegenteilige genauso
unbekannten wichtig nach der liebe
suchen bedeutet beides ein sehnen nach
sicherheit und die lust aufs unbekannte
darauf setzen diese beiden mit ihrer
dating plattform be my valentine
kostenlose dates per videochat für
singles die pandemie bedingt niemanden
treffen können mit 50 anmeldungen haben
sie gerechnet
aktuell sind sie bei 2000 ein
grosserfolg
für risi menschen matchen per excel
tabelle die plattform gründer
entscheiden persönlich auf gunter
antworten der user wer zu wem passt
nicht über kinder wo die suchenden
selbst entscheiden können wen sie decken
wollen sehen ob die spaß und jetzt
irgendwann sollte man eigentlich noch
oft als erstes zwei jahre wie man den
einfachen grund ich mache so etwas
anders für be my valentine arbeiten
derzeit 13 leute ehrenamtlich die macher
treten gegen den kommerziellen dating
wahnsinn an und ländern die einsamkeit
alleinstehenden in der krise das post
pandemie leben wartet aber schon auch
auf cosima freeh und franz perner
für die quarantäne paare kommt der
stress test mit dem regulären alltag als
genau das rückwärts prinzip einer
beziehung so lernt sich kennen wohnen
zusammen und jetzt löst sich diese nähe
irgendwie wird sich zwangsläufig
irgendwie wieder ein bisschen aufrecht
und so ein bisschen respekt davor
geschah corona lehrt uns den verzicht
die multi optionen des lebens zu
minimieren
gleichzeitig brachte die krise die
einmalige chance sich voll und ganz auf
eine neue liebe einzulassen
[Musik]
bitte sie einmal dran danke danke heißt
das jetzt dass ich mal im kino elite
aber heute klappen holz das eigentlich
mit zwar nach einem fitnesstraining
garni doppelter espresso wird winkel
aber sie machen die suche
kulturveranstaltungen sowie konzert-
oder stellt haus im duo oder so
[Musik]
ebenso wie schätzt du hat das jetzt
irgendwo darüber historisch lässt dass
sie 200 maßen umsatz erwartet netapp
schießt du das projekt stellt haus das
bandprojekt stelle hat sie schon
verabschiedet wurde der brandort an der
johannes maaß album braucht das heißt er
wird endlich stellen nach hause
schwimmen noch ändern
wie schlimm steht und aus das hat der
pastor soll man gott sei dank reserve
termine es ist wäre bankrott also es ist
der fokus klar dass es kein festival
sowie es fehlt an die gesellschaft
zurück ist nicht möglich ist danke
sellschaft fahrer unter sich
das ist nicht gleich ob man der wahren
segen des lettres de ich habe
beschlossen mich eigentlich nie
parkplatz war auch selber mehr dazu
erfahren sie wie so oft nicht mehr
rasieren
es ist so ein digital hektik und marco
ich glaube das nicht gemacht dass er das
traurigste ab die so groß ist ein
altersheim star wurde dann die hatte so
groß ist dass ich habe teilweise sehr
sie das war musik sie warum sie das
das ist medizin versorgt
und das macht mit
wenn du wirklich rico
wir hätten locker
wie lange der gate zu
[Musik]
mit dem album clair bio melancholie aus
cottbus ii betreuung in der luft schwebt
die gefühlslage wieder vororchesters
geschrieben als er es erwartet die gebe
zur größe hilfe der kulturpessimist ich
habe erwartet dass die katastrophe
bisschen blindenhund grad die ganze des
kreises kuppelförmige die große
hochklassig linie klären welcher das
herz nicht von der seite erwartete hat
zurzeit finanzkrise erwartet sondern
soll das schon aber das ist jetzt schon
speziell
bis 14
das virus das ist dass ich habe bisher
noch nicht das macht so landete der
umgang von der mannschaft
das hat mich das ist fraglich
auf der anderen seite wird ja nicht aber
an allem ist sie mit protest seine musik
machen dass derlei bedenken über das ist
ja nicht so dass ist eine kranken fühlen
ausschuss für unsere reihe sieben
künstlerinnen und ein virus haben wir
uns erkundigt was tut ihr eigentlich
während corona
seit wochen trainiert die tänzerin lisa
ordens kelbra allein für sich in ihre
wohnung
nun ist ein ende der quarantäne in sicht
ich freue mich darauf mich in einem
großen ballettsaal bewegen zu können
der countdown beginnt jetzt lisa hortons
kg ist eine von sieben künstlerinnen und
künstlern die uns videos schicken und
erzählen wie die korona krise ihr
kreatives leben beeinflusst am 11 mai
kehren sie ins theater zurück und
beginnen wieder zu arbeiten
ernst folgt in kleinen gruppen unter
bestimmten sicherheitsregeln und ja es
ist ein erster schritt und ich bin super
aufgeregt
die ersten schritte draußen am rheinufer
was wird einfließen aus der langen
corona zeit wenn die proben beginnen am
theater basel
[Musik]
die zeit der quarantäne war wie eine
lange emotionale reise so ja wir werden
alle etwas verlässliches und schönes
mitnehmen die atmosphäre wird magisch
sein
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ich bin katrin koudelka den seit bald 15
jahren geigerin hier im tonhalle
orchester zürich mein name ist michael
von schönermark ich bin solo fagottist
dem tonhalle orchester zürich und dozent
für vor gott an der hochschule luzern
für mich als musiker ist das positivste
an dieser situation sicherlich dass man
eine gewisse entschleunigung erlebt dass
man zeit hat sich mit musik anders zu
befassen als man es vorher getan hat
dass man stücke erleben kann wie man sie
sonst nicht erlebt weil man einfach
unter gewissem zeitdruck auch arbeiten
muss kathrin hotelcard mit anderen
musikerinnen und musikern des tonhalle
orchesters begonnen die zeit zu nutzen
und in alters und pflegeheimen zu
spielen
[Musik]
ja wir sind ohne irgendein konzert aber
viel schlimmer noch ohne irgendeine
konkrete aussicht auf konzerte in
nächster zeit die turnhalle ist dass
mindestens 8 juni weiterhin geschlossen
und ich merke wie mir das musizieren
richtig fehlt und bei aller kreativität
spontanität und vielseitigkeit die aus
diesen einschränkungen erwächst habe ich
doch eine tiefe sehnsucht nach einer
mozart oder schostakowitschs sinfonie
ich bin für hamburg und den bildenden
künsten die neue stelle in den städten
ist das thema eines kunstprojektes dass
veronika spiegelburg vor einigen wochen
schon initiiert hat und somit begonnen
dass mir als video zugespielt wurde ich
mit rio die sanierung neue strandstraße
und er kannte ich mich mal wirklich
bewusst in was für eine außergewöhnliche
krise mit länder sind mehr den gedanken
gemacht wie wir klingt mir dienen
hier stoße erstaunt was für sound rund
um den honig aus der häuser und haben
wir den aufzug macht nach tontechnikerin
auf der ganzen welt
so entstand eine website ein ton archiv
aus der zeit mit dem virus
es geht eigentlich darum über die
geister für deine stadt st
variationen der stille rio de janeiro
eine fußgängerzone in rom
der platz vor der tate modern in london
tontechnik
es ist interessant wenn man anfängt sich
nostalgisch über das zu fühlen was uns
früher so sehr missfiel
[Musik]
so im dezember wieder auf tour ja so
gott will oder nächsten sonntag in der
sternstunde philosophie und wir vom
kulturplatz wir blicken dann in unserer
nächsten sendung auf das kriegsende vor
65 jahren und auf den darauf folgenden
wandeln in der schweizer kulturszene ja
und hier auf sf1 geht's jetzt weiter mit
kleine lügen chef der umfrage wwg
offenbach spielertrainer
das land ziehen
was wir mit der gremium machte
[Musik]
mit ihrem einsatz bewegen wir kultur
swisslos
[Musik]